Chán Phô Thịt, Kỹ Sư Adi bỏ công việc lương cao về sống ẩn giật trong hàng á.
Sớm đẹp không đáng để tôi lắng phi tình và thời gian, niên kai, 3-5 tuổi,
từ là một Kỹ Sư Adi với mức lương hơn 1 miệng tệ mỗi tháng.
Chán nạn với nghiệp sống đô thiện một nạn, anh cứ định từ bỏ tất cả để đi tìm bình in đời lối dừng.
Nó nghe khu trong hai mời, anh cứ định bỏ phố về dừng, tìm thấy một hàng đà giữa vùng lối tư sinh và tự tay cải thảo thành tổ âm với chi phía khoảng 4 miệng tệng.
Hàng đà có định, internet, máy tính, ra sách và một mạnh vườn xanh mức.
Chúng giấu trước cửa, câu ca bên sống, đò mối hỏi là sống, anh chia sẻ,
mỗi ngày choo qua trong không giản yên tính, không đết lại, không áp lực,
hà mất mấy mùa hệ, ấm áp bùa đông, đủ để vinh coi đỏ là thi đường dương.
Nhưng điều khiến cộng đồng mạng suo sau nhất lại là quan điểm của anh về hôn nhân,
hành họ thi tốn tiền, chêu chủ thi tốn sức, đặc người không hợp thi chia tay, tiền mất, tiền tàn,
anh cho rằng trong thời đại này, trình hai người thật sự đồng điều với nhau đã rất hiện,
một bình lượng viết, người vợ, mua nhà, trả nửa ba binh năm,
nghĩ lại sống trong hàng còn tự do xuất đời, dù vậy, không ít người cho rằng đây là một cách tránh thực bếp,
cuộc sống đôi thi vậy dậy tôi cách để thành công,
còn cuộc sống trong hàng dậy tôi cách để hạnh phúc, ninh cảm thán.